actually he's with us in Georgia I
actually welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi there thank you so much for taking my
call
sure what's up my brand new to the
program we just my husband and I just
read your book I read it twice and we
just sorta listened to your podcast and
why you're itemizing all of our debt and
our mountain of student loans is just
super overwhelming we have one Great
Lakes loan that's 135,000 and it's
broken up into 15 different loans and so
I'm wondering if I should itemize each
of those loans and our snowball because
it won't affect whether like the minimum
payment right now is 128 dollars so
that's not going to like increase our
snowball at all and if we pay off one
it's not going to increase that snowball
at all so I just wanted your advice
about how we should attack that debt the
why does it not increase the snowball
because right now the minimum monthly
payment is 128 so we paid off that the
smallest one which is about two thousand
when I talk to the person on the phone
they told us know that the minimum
amount would stay the same it would
still be a hundred and twenty-eight
dollars also even though they break them
down there's only one payment correct
okay um and that's a hundred and
thirty-five thousand worth yeah fifteen
different loans that's that are a
hundred and twenty eight dollars for
$135 yeah I we're on an income based
repayment plan right now and I think
that's good for the next year and a half
yeah okay how much other debt do you
have our total is 192 thousand with
credit cards and my student loans how
much are the other student loans
I haven't that's fifteen hundred I
discover that's eight thousand I'm sorry
the nevians fifteen thousand discovers
eight thousand and first mark is six
that we so about thirty thousand there
that's a hot so that's one hundred and
sixty five of your 192 right mm-hmm
right a card that we have
1,000 2,000 3,000 and 8,000 okay and how
much y'all in your car we owe 11,500
okay what's your household income right
now 65,000 my husband is a doctor so he
is not like a medical doctor regular
philosophy doctor so not wasn't a smart
decision so we working on getting
another higher paying job getting a
bigger shovel that's our goal
so he has a PhD in philosophy not in
philosophy it's political science but
Owens okay let's run banks good and your
degrees in what English and that was the
135 no my degree is there sellin his was
the 135 correct so that includes like
his undergrad yeah and masters PhD okay
and so what do you earn I of that amount
I earn about twenty five thousand so you
working full-time I'm working part-time
I'm working on getting another part-time
job or bring the beginning stages so
we're both going to be getting part-time
jobs to help make our bigger shovel yeah
so what are your career paths what are
you gonna do my husband wants to he
wanted to teach at a college level and
it just takes a little while for those
jobs ago he just graduated not too long
ago a year out and the average time to
gain employment after that is about
three years of applying so he has a
little bit more time but it needs to be
sooner rather than later and if that
doesn't pan out then he'll be looking at
more government positions City Planning
positions that kind of thing
what about you well we have two young
kids right now so I am teaching English
online but my kids will go to school in
about two years and then I I don't know
help figure out a path I think okay
because I'm just looking at ya you keep
talking about the size of your shovel so
you've been
to me because your ratio your ratio of
shovel is 60000 income to 192 and debt
is a problem right we're living right
now I'm 30 thousands and I'm hoping to
keep it that way
where is being family yeah but with you
being with you being at home with the
small kids you are a full-time home
economist so you can keep the cost of
living down to nothing doing that yeah
but there's only so much you can lower
costs in you know just the ratio of you
know thirty thousand into two hundred is
a seven-year plan I don't want to do
that one yeah neither so I want to do
that one to a three-year plan and so I
need an extra $60,000 a year from
somewhere which he'll get if he gets a
PhD position at a college
mmm-hmm I mean that'll pop him it'll pop
him up into six figures probably
depending on where he's so competitive
and it's been really really difficult
applying for those jobs and yeah there's
not that many of them and there's a lot
of people have this idea that that's a
career track so young so everybody's
gonna be working on everything they can
get their hands on which is what you're
doing on the short term until we can get
some long term income really coming in
and that's what you guys are facing here
so with all of that in mind you're not
changing this income reason I'm asking
all this question I'm trying to find
about the income based repayment on the
135 and $128 that's you're not going to
get to that for a long time I would lump
that 135 is one big debt at the end of
your debt snowball okay that's what we
have now okay you had thought through
that properly I was just trying to make
sure I had the facts before I said
normally I would not do that but it's
gonna be a while before you get to that
puppy and your income pay your income is
still going to be calculated on the
lower income during the time we're
knocking out these smaller ones so it
would be very very cool if we were down
to 135 you you would be there too
current trek in two years yeah that's
what that's our baby too bad and by then
hopefully your incomes are ramping up
and we knocked the 130 at 5 out real
fast I hope you ramp them up faster than
that but that's your worst-case scenario
is you're gonna get there and you'll be
debt-free
up that so the good news is you've
stopped the bleeding you turn the ship
around we're heading back to port we're
gonna get there back where we're safe
again and get this deck cleaned up but
yeah I think I'm going to treat the 135
since it's income based repayment it's
only 128 it doesn't move the needle on
that as one lump sum until we get there
now once we do get to it
then we'll knock it off smallest to
largest in the 15 loans that comprise
the 135 because the smallest the larger
so give you the sense of traction the
sense that you're getting somewhere and
that's what you want from that is the
psychological feedback of going woo one
down woohoo another one down you need
those whoo-hoo moments in the midst of a
trek like your own so you sound very
determined very dialed in you're very up
on your numbers there's a lot of good
signs in this conversation and that
you're going the right way so be
encouraged you will get there and if you
get scared or get tired along the way
you call me we'll talk it through
together